[Applause]
dwayne wade
to produce the redeem team documentary
how do we feel about that
yeah i didn't top it with now everybody
want to do a documentary hollywood
loves to be second to the [ __ ] dance
huh it's like
the second one thing pops everybody in
hollywood every producer is like oh
grace and agent told me this he said
about la but it's all in all hollywood
are all like show business they're in a
big race to come in second
nobody wants to be the first last dance
let's make the next the last dance
and it's not going to be as good you
know an interesting documentary
go the uh them three joining up in miami
how that all happened
that i like that but i i i'm talking
about when they lost
the u.s team that lost what was going on
in that locker room yeah what was going
on with the media
when allen iverson went out there
thinking he was going to win for the
first time in his life and he ends up
getting bronzed
wow i really thought you were going to
say his kids transition but
that's a doc how do you know you'd not
that gender at nine except yeah
was your first dance bro
son real talk dude what the [ __ ]
nine years old i feel like at nine years
old you should be able to say cut that
[ __ ] out yo
you should that that was the debate
people were like nah nah nah chill out
isn't that what busy said yeah oh
my god oh my gosh
don't call me you cut his [ __ ] off bro
boosie is gut
busy is i was just gonna say bussie
could do this show
busy is good and that's why we resonate
with him so much
it's gut this is how we you know who's
gut duval
gut yeah no affiliation nothing this is
the truth this is what it is
and busy says in his way and duval this
says in his way
but and busy he says it with this accent
it's gonna be like
hood hooded up a little bit but if you
can get past that [ __ ] and you just
listen what he's saying
it's just raw don't lie bro
come on yo you can't agree with that at
nine years old
and not you ain't got no pubes yet you
haven't even gone through puberty at all
you do anything at nine years old they
were dressing dennis robin's sisters was
dressing dennis robin up as a girl at
nine years old
by [ __ ] kevin spacey at nine years
old yeah that's right kevin spacey trump
what you're saying is dwyane wade's son
is going to be the greatest rebounder in
the history of the nba
dude honestly if he went back to being a
man that'd be an amazing rebound
no real talk dude you got to cut that
[ __ ] out i'm sorry
when can your kid start being who they
are
i'm gonna be honest with you i'm gonna
be honest with you go 13.
would say sixteen bro i mean yo
you could drive yourself to the clinic
[ __ ]
hey i ain't taking you real talk i'm not
driving my kids to the clinic to get
their dick cut off ain't gonna happen
all right this ain't patriotic mean that
what age should they be able to beat
himself hey this is gut yo
we always operate through gut here let
me flip it though let's say you have
five daughters one
wants to become a man you always wanted
a son oh yeah do that [ __ ]
four years old what's up sew a dick on
this little [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
that [ __ ] flapping like the thing
outside the car dealership
yes i'm a grown-ass dick on this little
[ __ ]
hey there timothy go show your grandma
your dick real quick go sell you a brand
new dick
come on you can't get a used dick off a
cadaver or something like that you can
definitely
you know when some [ __ ] die and then
she donates her like lungs
to like save people's lives you know
what i'm talking about yeah yeah like
they're brain dead so they can use all
the body parts
yeah oh god you should be able to get a
dick off somebody yo
right i'm afraid to check that box on
you what's
your ideas organ donation yeah yeah i
don't do that i think if i check it
out my organs are too good somebody
wants you think they're gonna take your
dick
yeah they're gonna oh they take your
dick they want that but they're gonna
take you they're like they're not gonna
try to save you as much
that's what i feel yeah hell yeah no no
that's my organs i came here with these
organs
you don't know if you need it yeah but
what if like
they put your eyes in somebody else's
eyes and then you just keep saying
you're not seeing nothing not but you
just keep saying all right what if they
put you in a girl's eyes you does that
even mean
they're not just looking at my tits all
day what what first of all
that's a good point actually they put
your eyes in a girl's eye she's just
getting nutted on all [ __ ] day that's
what you want your eyes to do bro
i mean you got tits now what about the
upside
girls don't be looking at their own tits
you feel them you can't
do it all day you can't it's not like
your hands are being given
your eyes are going to be good you're
just going to look at some dude you're
going to look down a [ __ ] urethra
for the rest of your life that's like
that vr pawn so
you look down i got a white dick now
that [ __ ] is weird yeah i'm gonna be
honest
i'm i think i'm saying something here
this is the least scientifically valid
discussion we've ever had
what you need what you talking about
bro
you're saying the wrong number is it
idiot
no marcus 7 11.
you played something yo thank god they
didn't do that [ __ ] in july i'd have
never heard the end of that boy
that was the [ __ ] worst and best day
of my life
i can't get that [ __ ] slurpee from
7-eleven without having to deal with
this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh boy
yeah it was brilliant oh man i don't
know man i think i'm right
about a lot of things today to be honest
with you but
i think i'm right about you should
decide when your kid gets to be what
they want
okay i asked my dad for a tongue ring he
said no
i'm glad he did yeah wow my dad's only
said no to two things to me in my entire
life
one playing hockey tongue ring might be
gay than getting your dick cut off real
talk
dude i would let my kid get the dick cut
off before getting a tongue oh
yep you wobble it out bro listen i know
i was wild but there was a kid named
anthony who like got girls pregnant in
my high school he had one i was like
that seems pretty cool
uh and then uh so i wanted i asked my
dad he goes no
and then he goes to me he goes honestly
i would rather you get a full sleeve
tattoo
than you get a tongue ring and he's
never gonna be pushed back anything and
the other thing i was like
in like [ __ ] third grade or something
i wanted to play hockey
and i had a friend who wanted was
playing hockey quamina panford
was the kid's name and uh yeah jamaican
and uh and uh my dad was like no you
can't play hockey
i was like why not he goes yeah you just
can't play it and later on he told me
he's like you're not gonna be able to
make friends like that
growing up like basketball's a skill
that you can go anywhere in the world
and play and then you can meet and like
build relationships with and all my
friends that i had outside of comedy are
for basketball
literally all of them so he was right
but imagine that only two times he gave
pushback that's how bad tongue rings are
you know what i mean he's like you're
not gonna be able to make friends with
this [ __ ] tongue ring
sound tendering so bad they made your
dad homophobic real talk
my dad is in a [ __ ] dance studio
seeing real gay people
all the time oh boy i've never seen a
tongue ring and not
think they don't suck dick 100 percent
and that's including men
100 percent 100 oh [ __ ]
but that's a good thing so it's like he
made that decision that i wasn't allowed
to do what i wanted he saved your life
he saved my life yeah he really did
i think that dwayne we got to take
dwyane wade's kid away from him
stop like this is [ __ ] i think
[Applause]
finally
you